Es ist wie ein schlechter Traum,
aus dem ich gerne aufwachen möchte.
Die Situation
ist für mich unvorstellbar.
Manchmal fragt man sich,
wann das aufhört.
Man wartet und hofft darauf,
doch es wird immer schlimmer.
Corona betrifft uns alle.
Doch die Jungen
schränkt es wohl am stärksten ein.
Wir können nicht mehr ausgehen,
sehen unsere Kollegen seltener,
Dating wurde sehr schwierig
und Reisen eigentlich unmöglich.
Mir persönlich sind
soziale Kontakte sehr wichtig.
Das schlägt mir sonst auf die Psyche.
Wie gehen wir
mit diesem Ausnahmezustand um?
Kommen wir irgendwann
an unsere Grenzen?
Verschiedene Menschen erzählen mir,
wie sie das Dilemma
zwischen sozialer Verantwortung und
eingeschränkter Freiheit wahrnehmen.
Wenn das, was man immer getan hat,
plötzlich illegal ist.
Das ist nicht schön.
Eines ist klar: Corona
geht an niemandem spurlos vorbei.
Von der Erkrankung bis zum Tod
dauerte es eine Woche.
Ich vermisse sie schon.
Als erstes treffe ich zwei,
die die Pandemie hautnah miterleben.
- Hoi, Coco.
- Hoi.
Wie geht's?
Corinna und Melanie studieren
und arbeiten im Gesundheitswesen.
Samstagabends gehen sie nicht aus,
sondern zur Nachtschicht
ins Krankenhaus.
Wird es nie eng, wenn ihr beim
Homeschooling nahe aufeinander seid?
Bisher kommen wir
gut aneinander vorbei.
Mühsam ist nur, dass wir
nur einen Wohnzimmertisch haben.
Wir sind ergonomisch
mit Pult und Stuhl eingerichtet.
Aber wir kamen bisher
sehr gut aneinander vorbei.
Ja.
Habt ihr nie einen Koller gekriegt?
Ich fand es zu Beginn
schon ziemlich schwierig.
Wenn ich mich
mit meinem Umfeld getroffen habe,
wussten wir nicht recht,
ob wir uns umarmen sollen oder nicht.
Mir ist das wichtig,
ich brauche den Kontakt.
Wir sind in der Regel soziale Wesen.
Ich habe mein soziales Umfeld
stark eingeschränkt.
Mir hat geholfen,
dass Corinna zu Hause ist.
Drei Monate alleine zu Hause zu sein,
ohne jemanden zu sehen,
wäre für mich unmöglich.
Während des Lockdowns haben wir uns
eigentlich an alles gehalten.
Ich arbeite jetzt in der Pflege,
sie hat mal in der Pflege gearbeitet.
Ich fühle mich dem Gesundheitswesen,
dem Arbeitgeber gegenüber
schon etwas verpflichtet,
dass ich nicht kopflos jedes
Wochenende etwas unternommen,
mit mich 50 Leuten getroffen habe.
Es gibt gewisse Dinge,
die ich im Nachhinein gesehen
vielleicht nicht hätte machen sollen.
Wenn man jung und Single
in einer Stadt ist,
möchte man vielleicht mal daten.
Da trifft man vielleicht
mal jemanden,
obwohl man das
nicht hätte tun sollen.
Aber es gehört einfach zum Leben.
- Der sieht sehr lecker aus.
- Der Salat?
Ja, sehr gut.
Sehr schön.
Man überlegt sich ganz anders,
ob man jemanden trifft.
Man fragt, bzw. ich frage die Person
beispielsweise:
"Wie verhältst du dich?"
Wenn sie jedes Woche mit Leuten
weggeht, ist für mich klar,
dass ich die Person nicht treffe.
Wenn ich jetzt jemanden treffe, gehe
ich oft mit der Person spazieren.
Da ist man an der frischen Luft,
hat Abstand,
spricht sich nicht direkt an.
Und Sexting ist total Corona-konform.
- Es gibt also Wege, oder?
- Das stimmt.
Es ist klar,
dass wir Abstand halten müssen.
Wir lernen uns jetzt erst kennen.
Es läuft nicht nur
aufs Körperliche hinaus.
Das finde ich persönlich
gar nicht so schlecht.
Viele sind trotzdem ausgegangen.
Sie wurde dafür
sehr stark kritisiert.
Man sagte, sie wollten
einfach Party machen und saufen.
Hedonismus über alles.
Und doch geht man nicht nur aus ...
um zu saufen.
Kannst du das
teilweise nachvollziehen
oder gibt es für dich
nur Schwarz und Weiss?
Es gibt auch Grau,
nicht nur Schwarz oder Weiss.
Auch wir sind mal ausgegangen.
Aber mit Mass,
wie ich das selbst vertreten konnte.
Ich fühle mich dem Gesundheitswesen
gegenüber verpflichtet.
Ich war nicht wahl- und kopflos
jedes Wochenende an einem Rave.
Es geht nicht nur
ums Saufen, Komasaufen etc.
Es geht darum, gemeinsam
eine gute Zeit zu verbringen.
Das brauchten wir,
das wollte ich auch.
Wenn ich danach niemanden gesehen
habe, konnte ich das verantworten.
Vor dem 80. Geburtstag
ihres Grossvaters
wäre ich sicher nicht ausgegangen.
Ich glaube,
das hängt nicht vom Alter ab.
Ich möchte nicht,
dass jemand wegen mir krank ist
und schlimmstenfalls stirbt.
Ich glaube,
da überwiegt die Vernunft dann doch.
- Ist gut?
- Ja.
- Tschau, meine Liebe.
- Tschau.
Danke.
Wie wenig Bock hast du,
wenn du am Samstagabend im Tram sitzt
und andere ausgehen?
Ob während Corona oder nicht -
arbeiten am Wochenende ist nie geil,
wenn andere ausgehen.
Gestern habe ich ein paar
ca. 20-jährige Jugendliche gesehen,
die im Tram Zigaretten angezündet
und keine Masken getragen haben.
Ich habe mir lange überlegt,
etwas zu sagen.
Aber ich war auf dem Weg zum
Nachtdienst, ich muss arbeiten gehen.
Ich habe mit COVID-Patienten zu tun.
Es war so offensichtlich,
dass sie einen Scheiss darauf geben.
Das fand ich sehr respektlos.
Ich war gerade in meinem Nachtdienst-
Mood und sehe dieses Verhalten.
Da musste ich fast etwas sagen.
Wir haben uns lustigerweise
ein Themenverbot erteilt.
- In der WG?
- In der WG, mit Kollegen.
Denn alle arbeiten
im Gesundheitswesen.
Wir sprachen über irgendein Thema,
nach 10 Min. wieder nur über Corona.
Es beschäftigt einen einfach.
Man muss fast darüber sprechen.
- Ja.
- Auch wenn man nicht will.
Ja.
Ich komme.
Willkommen im Bunker.
Aber hier unten
finde ich es echt etwas creepy.
Wie lange dauert deine Schicht?
Von 22.30 Uhr
bis morgen früh um 7.15 Uhr.
Krass. Also fast 9 Std.
- Ja.
- Wie lange hast du Pause?
Wir können keine Patienten abgeben,
weil wir im Nachtdienst
nur zu zweit sind.
Wir versuchen Pause zu machen,
wann es geht.
- Krass.
- Ja.
Es ist vorgeschrieben,
dass wir eine Maske
und eine Schutzbrille dabei haben.
Die neue Regelung schreibt vor, dass
auch Patienten Masken tragen müssen.
Deshalb erübrigt sich
das mit der Brille ein wenig.
Dein Job ist ohnehin schon streng,
in den vergangenen Monaten
wurde es noch schlimmer.
Die Flexibilität,
die wir an den Tag legen müssen,
aufgrund der
sich ständig ändernden Massnahmen.
Das ist viel strenger geworden.
Ich arbeite nicht hochprozentig.
Wenn ich nach einer Woche
zurück ins Krankenhaus komme,
hat es wieder Änderungen gegeben -
das ist eine Herausforderung.
Aber das Team
arbeitet sehr gut zusammen.
Das war eigentlich
eine schöne Entwicklung.
Es ist fast wie Teambuilding.
- Welcome to my crib.
- Hast du ...
Gibt es Ausnahmesituationen
hier im Krankenhaus,
die dir in Erinnerung geblieben sind?
Während der Corona-Situation
sind mir die Suizidversuche
in Erinnerung geblieben -
aufgrund von Corona.
Gewisse Menschen können schlechter
mit Isolation umgehen als andere.
Es trifft sie viel härter.
Man hat gemerkt,
dass die Existenz dieser Menschen
von der Pandemie betroffen ist.
Macht dir das Angst?
Ja, weil ich nicht weiss,
wie lange das so weitergeht.
Unser Lebens ist stark eingeschränkt,
das ist ungewohnt.
Man gewöhnt sich daran, in der
zweiten Welle kennen wir das Ganze.
Aber ich möchte nicht
den Rest meines Lebens so verbringen.
Das Klatschen ist schön und gut,
ein wichtiger Anfang
und sicher auch
ein wichtiges Zeichen.
Die Notwendigkeit, dass wir
zu wenig Pflegepersonal haben
und schon immer hatten -
es wird Zeit, das mal aufzuzeigen.
Aber das Klatschen ist nur
ein Tropfen auf den heissen Stein.
Wir brauchen eindeutig mehr Leute.
Leute, die nach der Ausbildung
in der Pflege bleiben,
denen es auch nach langer Zeit
in der Pflege psychisch gut geht.
Im Moment ist es allen sehr bewusst.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl,
wenn nicht bald etwas geschieht,
gerät das in Vergessenheit,
das ist meine Sorge.
Es ist 22.27 Uhr,
in 3 Min. beginnt dein Dienst.
Wir lassen dich mal gehen.
Vielen Dank für deine Zeit
und danke für deine Arbeit.
Gerne. Vielen Dank.
- Dann noch einen schönen Abend.
- Tschüss zusammen.
Wenn man so etwas sieht ...
Wir alle haben uns
irgendwie eingeschränkt.
Dann sieht man, was sie macht,
und denkt sich:
"Ich habe vergleichsweise wirklich
überhaupt kein Problem wegen Corona."
Manchmal tut das ganz gut,
dieser Realitycheck.
Krankenhäuser sind für Realitychecks
meist kein schlechter Ort.
Ich habe kürzlich die Biografie
von Dani Koch gesehen und dachte,
er und Berset waren im Frühling
die absoluten Helden.
Es gab sogar einen Quarantäne-Fanshop
mit T-Shirts.
Das hat sich etwas geändert.
Der Bundesrat wird hinterfragt.
Die Medien werden kritisiert -
nicht ganz zu unrecht.
Auch die Massnahmen
werden hinterfragt.
Das macht auch Flavio.
Ich bin gespannt
auf das Gespräch mit ihm.
Hey. Hoi, Flavio. Hey.
- Wie geht's?
- Gut.
Gehen wir etwas in die Höhe,
um eine Aussicht zu haben?
Sehr gut.
Du warst gerade auf einer dreitägigen
Fahrradtour. Was hat dir das gegeben?
Es war nice,
mal die Schweiz zu sehen.
Ich habe noch nie Ferien
in diesem Stil gemacht.
Freiheit,
man konnte machen, was man will.
Es war geil.
Gehörst du zu den Corona-Kritikern
oder -Skeptikern?
Ich würde mich nicht
als Corona-Kritiker ...
Doch, Kritiker vielleicht schon,
weil ich es kritisch betrachte.
Es ist ja etwas ziemlich Grosses.
Ich habe noch nie so etwas erlebt.
Wenn ich nicht wirklich weiss,
wo ich mich informieren kann,
wo die Informationen korrekt sind,
betrachte ich das schon kritisch,
aber ich sage nicht:
"Corona gibt es nicht"
oder "Masken sind schädlich".
Ich bin gespannt, wie wir
in fünf Jahren darauf zurückschauen.
Wenn wir wissen,
was wirklich gewesen ist.
Wenn Zeit vorbeigeht, kann man
alles viel nüchterner betrachten.
Wie informierst du dich im Moment
über Corona,
damit du weisst,
was noch erlaubt ist und was nicht?
Über Corona informiere ich mich
nicht mehr gross im Internet.
Wenn es einen Post
über die neuen Regeln gibt,
was man noch darf und was nicht,
vielleicht schon.
Aber die Zahl der Infiziert usw.
interessiert mich nicht.
Ich lese nur das, was mich betrifft.
Was sollten die Medien deiner Meinung
nach besser machen?
Sie sollten keine Angst schüren
oder Angst machen
und alles so schlimm darstellen.
Wir können ja noch einigermassen
so leben, wie wir möchten.
Aber es wird so dargestellt,
als wäre es der grosse Weltuntergang.
Was waren für dich
die krassesten Einschränkungen?
Die krasseste Einschränkung
war zu Beginn die Fünf-Personen-Regel
in der Öffentlichkeit.
Es wurde langsam Sommer,
alle hatten Bock, draussen zu sein.
Ich selbst wurde nie gebüsst,
aber Kollegen von mir,
weil sie zu sechst,
zu siebt draussen waren.
Da war nicht
wirklich nachvollziehbar,
was den Unterschied macht.
Da fühlte man sich etwas wehrlos,
das war unangenehm.
Wenn das, was man immer gemacht hat,
plötzlich illegal ist.
Das kann man nicht nachvollziehen.
Wenn einem etwas verboten wird,
das ist nicht schön.
Ich habe einen Facebookpost gesehen:
"Impfen macht frei".
Ich dachte mir, fuck,
wir befinden uns in einer Zeit,
in der sich Nazis mit irgendwelchen
Naturheilpraktikern verschwören.
Diese Entwicklung
macht mir ziemlich Angst.
Ich würde sagen,
das zeigt wahrscheinlich,
dass Corona im Moment
über allem steht.
Dass das im Moment ...
Es stellt die Gesinnungen von früher
auf die Seite,
weil im Moment ist Corona da.
Ich weiss nicht.
Ist Corona ein so grosser Deal?
Vielen Dank für deine Zeit,
noch einen schönen Abend.
- Bleib gesund!
- Gleichfalls, du auch.
- Tschüss.
- Tschüss, Flavio.
Was Flavio sagt, ist schon krass.
Dass linke Menschen
mit Nazis demonstrieren,
weil ihre Differenzen im Vergleich
zu Corona so klein werden,
ist irgendwie ...
... überhaupt nicht gut.
... sehr stark antikapitalistisch,
marxistisch eingestellt bin.
Menschen wie Silvan
sehen auch die Vorteile von Corona.
Z.B., dass immer mehr Menschen
unser System hinterfragen.
Ich glaube,
viele haben einerseits bemerkt,
dass wir den ganzen Konsum
nicht brauchen.
Andererseits, dass der Kapitalismus
überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Ja, dieses Gefühl hatte ich auch.
V.a. in meinem Umfeld
sind viele Menschen
etwas antikapitalistischer geworden.
Das hat wohl vieles aufgezeigt.
Ohne Massentierhaltung hätte es
Corona wahrscheinlich nicht gegeben.
Ohne die ganzen internationalen Flüge
hätte es sich
nicht so schnell verbreitet.
Es hat einen Schleier für bereits
existierende Probleme gelüftet.
Sie wurden jetzt einfach sichtbarer.
Ich sehe das Problem
eher in der Massentierhaltung
als in der Globalisierung.
Alleine die Krankheiten,
die von Tieren übertragen wurden -
die Schweinegrippe, SARS kam von
einem Tier aus, jetzt auch COVID-19.
Das wäre nie geschehen,
wenn wir alle vegan wären.
Aber andererseits kann man
den Menschen nicht vorwerfen:
"Du bist mit schuld an COVID,
weil du dich nicht vegan ernährst."
Wünschst du dir, dass mehr Menschen
ihren Lebenswandel hinterfragen
aufgrund der Pandemie?
Ich glaube, wenn man sich
keine Gedanken darüber macht,
ist man entweder ein wenig ...
Dann ist man
fast ein wenig zu ignorant.
Ich glaube, die wenigsten Menschen
hätten sich jemals Gedanken
über den Kapitalismus oder
über vegane Ernährung gemacht,
wenn wir jetzt nicht
eine solche Pandemie hätten.
Ich mache ziemlich oft Yoga.
Und ich musste feststellen:
Die Schnittmenge ist ziemlich gross
zwischen den Fühlst-du-mich-Menschen,
die ich sehr mag,
zu denen, die finden,
Homöopathie helfe schon gegen Corona
und nur Licht und Liebe.
Ich habe irgendwann ein paar solche
Bekanntschaften auf Facebook gemutet.
Vielleicht hätte ich sie
damit konfrontieren sollen,
aber irgendwann konnte ich nicht mehr
jeden Tag so viel Bullshit lesen.
Hattest du solche Menschen
in deinem Umfeld
und wie gingst du mit ihnen um?
Ich habe sehr viele Menschen in
meinem Umfeld, die ähnlich reagieren.
Ein Kollege,
den ich im Zivi kennenlernte,
ist sehr anfällig
für Verschwörungstheorien usw.
Er ist jetzt Teil einer Gruppierung,
die sich QAnon nennt.
Er ist in meinem Alter, auch 21,
und eine sehr liebenswerte Person.
Er meint das nicht böse.
Er meint ...
Er warnt uns alle vor diesem Hoax,
was gerade passiert.
Er ist fest davon überzeugt.
Ich denke, es ist trotzdem wichtig,
das ernst zu nehmen.
Wenn man sich als Mensch
nicht respektiert fühlt,
nervt das einen auch.
Sie meinen es ja gut.
Wenn das Leben an einem Ort
einigermassen normal weitergeht -
was auch immer das bedeutet -
dann an der Langstrasse in Zürich.
Wir treffen jetzt Filippa, die sich
das Feiern nicht nehmen lässt.
- Hey.
- Hallo.
- Wie geht's?
- Sehr gut.
Gut.
Wie gerne würdest du jetzt feiern
gehen, wenn wir schon da sind?
Wenn ich diesen Balkon beobachte,
möchte ich gerne mal wieder
an einen Technorave gehen.
Wann war der letzte?
Der letzte richtige war ...
... vor dem ersten Lockdown,
also irgendwann im Januar.
- Scheisse.
- Ja.
- Das ist bald ein Jahr her.
Hast du die Massnahmen
immer streng eingehalten?
Nein, nicht immer.
Im ÖV und in den Geschäften etc.
halte ich mich auf jeden Fall dran.
Das finde ich auch wichtig.
Aber niemanden zu treffen -
daran habe ich mich nicht gehalten.
Also warst du an Privatpartys
mit mehr als zehn Leuten?
Ja.
Du gingst im Bewusstsein dorthin,
dass du gerade gegen eine
Anweisung des Bundesrats verstösst.
- Ja.
- War das präsent in diesem Moment?
Ja, voll.
Wenn das jemand sieht,
der z.B. eine erkrankte Person kennt,
und sagt, es sei passiert,
weil die Menschen keine Acht geben -
verstehst du, wenn die Person
dich als egoistisch bezeichnet?
Ja, das würde ich verstehen.
Ich bin mir dessen bewusst,
dass es provokativ ist.
Es gibt sicher Menschen,
die überhaupt nicht
mit mir übereinstimmen
oder finden, dass mein Verhalten
grob fahrlässig ist.
Dessen bin ich mir voll bewusst.
Wir haben schon einige Male
zusammen geredet.
Du bist sehr reflektiert,
altruistisch, auch empathisch.
Wenn man das hört,
passt es irgendwie nicht so zu dir.
Weisst du, was ich meine?
Mir persönlich sind
soziale Kontakte sehr wichtig.
Es schlägt mir sonst
wirklich auf die Psyche.
Wenn ich zu wenig
soziale Kontakte habe,
bin ich zu Hause
und es geht mir schlecht.
Ich will mein Bestes geben
in Bezug auf die Hygiene.
Ich möchte aber nicht meine
psychische Gesundheit gefährden.
Da gibt es für mich eine Grenze.
Ja.
Dazu kommt noch:
Das Immunsystem wird extrem gestärkt
durch körperlichen
und sozialen Kontakt.
Und was wir hier tun,
spricht komplett dagegen.
Ja.
Man kann sich ja
mit ein paar Menschen treffen.
Wieso reichen dir
vier oder fünf Menschen nicht?
Es ist schwierig, zu viert
eine Art Atmosphäre zu entwickeln.
Die ganze Atmosphäre,
die ein Klub ausstrahlt,
extrem viele Menschen an einem Ort,
man kann Vollgas lostanzen.
Man fühlt sich frei,
kann sich voll gehen lassen.
Mit vier Personen macht man das
nicht, das ist peinlich.
Was hat dir geholfen in dieser Zeit,
was sind deine Strategien,
um damit umzugehen?
Jene Momente, die ich mit
über zehn Menschen verbringe,
sind jene Momente, die mir helfen.
Das sind quasi kleine Inseln.
Von Leben?
- Genau.
Atmosphäre, Leben, Lebendigkeit.
Dann geht es wieder für eine gewisse
Zeit, dann halte ich es aus.
Hilft es, sich zu denken,
in einem Jahr -
oder in zwei Jahren -
ist es hoffentlich vorbei?
Ja, hoffentlich früher.
Gehst du hier lang?
- Ja, hier.
Hey, vielen Dank.
Bis hoffentlich bald in einem Klub.
Genau. Tschüss!
- Tschüss, Filippa!
So nahe wie jetzt kommen wir wohl
nicht mehr ans Thema ran.
Wir treffen Bert.
Er war gestern an der Beerdigung
seiner Oma, die an Corona starb.
Hoi.
Ja, willkommen.
- Vielen Dank.
Danke, dass es so
kurzfristig geklappt hat.
Wie geht es dir nach gestern?
Es ist wie ein Dreieck der Gefühle.
Da ist Frust, aber auch eine grosse
Trauer wegen meiner Grossmutter.
Es ist auch ein wenig Wut in mir.
Corona sitzt einem im Nacken
und man kann nichts mehr tun.
Bei jedem Schritt, jeder Bewegung
hat man ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Wenn ich den Kuchen schneide,
fürchte ich schon,
ihn durch die Berührung
zu kontaminieren.
In den ersten Tagen weinte ich viel.
Sie hat mich mit erzogen.
Wenn meine Eltern gearbeitet haben.
Ich habe noch nie
einen toten Menschen gesehen.
Sie tot auf dem Krankenbett zu sehen,
ist schon ziemlich heavy.
Und schliesslich
bin ich auch ziemlich wütend.
Weil ich immer noch nicht verstehe,
dass nach neun Monaten
die Menschen noch nicht verstehen,
dass man die Massnahmen ...
Dass man sich dran halten soll,
eine Maske tragen, die Hände waschen,
die Hände desinfizieren,
Abstand halten soll.
Ja, darum ist es gerade
eine kleine Achterbahn der Gefühle.
- Das tut mir leid.
- Schon gut.
Ja.
Die Ärzte sagten schon seit zwei
Jahren, es gehe nicht mehr lange.
Aber jetzt passierte es abrupt.
Sie ist ...
Innerhalb einer Woche ist sie ...
Von der Erkrankung
bis zum Tod dauerte es eine Woche.
Man kann nichts dagegen tun.
Sie wurde 91 Jahre alt,
das ist ein stolzes Alter.
Aber es hätte nicht
wegen Corona sein müssen.
Ja, ich vermisse sie schon.
Brauchst du eine Pause?
- Nein, ist gut.
Wie war die Beerdigung?
Es war schön.
Fast jedes Enkelkind
hat etwas vorgetragen.
Ausser jene, die in Indonesien leben.
Sie konnten wegen Corona
nicht in die Schweiz reisen.
Ich habe über Facebook
einen Livestream geschalten.
Dort mussten sie es anschauen,
weil es nicht anders ging.
Ein Stream ist auch nur ein kalter
Tropfen auf dem heissen Stein.
Es ist nicht ...
Wegen Corona kann man
nicht wirklich Abschied nehmen.
Es ist alles distanziert.
Ja.
Das macht es nicht einfacher.
Wie geht es dir, wenn du draussen
Menschen ohne Masken siehst
oder solche,
die Partys veranstalten wollen?
In erster Linie denke ich:
"Verpisst auch alle nach Hause,
bitte."
Auf der anderen Seite
verstehe ich es auch.
Es ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert.
Auf der anderen Seite sind
Veranstalter und Leute im Nachtleben.
Ich frage mich auch, wohin das führt,
wenn es so weitergeht.
Dann wird es keine Klubs mehr geben,
keine Veranstalter.
Wo bleibt dann noch der ganze Spass?
Was sollen wir Jungen ...
... in einem Jahr noch tun?
Wie fühlt es sich an, arbeiten zu
gehen? Bist du froh, rauszukommen?
Ich bin momentan froh um Ablenkung,
um ...
... darüber hinwegzukommen.
Ich freue mich sowieso immer
auf die Arbeit in der Bar.
Das ist wie ein Hobby,
das zum Beruf wurde.
Also nicht das Trinken,
sondern das Mixen.
Ja.
- Et voilà, bitte schön.
- Vielen Dank.
- Bert, auf deine Oma. Vielen Dank.
- Auf meine Oma.
- Ah, nice.
- Ist er gut?
- Er ist richtig nice, super.
- Er ist ein wenig zu süss.
Bis jetzt läuft es hier
noch relativ gut.
Aber um 23 Uhr ist Sperrstunde,
v.a. am Wochenende merkt man das.
Und trotzdem bist du eigentlich
für einen Lockdown?
Ich bin eindeutig dafür,
aber er muss klar finanziert sein.
Jetzt haben viele Bars bis zur
Sperrstunde um 23 Uhr geöffnet.
Ihr Umsatz ist weder richtig gut,
noch richtig schlecht.
Die meisten kommen knapp durch.
Ich bin klar für einen Lockdown,
aber er muss finanziert sein.
So könnten alle runterfahren,
es gibt ein gesichertes Einkommen,
man weiss, was läuft.
Ich persönlich wünsche mir ...
Wie man es überall liest und hört:
Wenn man sich krank fühlt,
soll man zu Hause bleiben.
Abstand halten,
Hände waschen und desinfizieren.
Wir sollten alles Mögliche tun,
damit wir irgendwann
einen normalen Betrieb,
Freizeit, Spass haben,
Liebe verbreiten können.
- Vielen Dank.
- Danke auch.
Ich hoffe, du findest in den nächsten
Tagen ein wenig Zeit für dich.
Ja, am Sonntag dann.
Danke.
Hallo zusammen. Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich bin Anne-Sophie
und mache eine Repo über ...
Für Bert wird es wegen der
Sperrstunde eine kurze Nacht.
Und somit auch für seine Gäste.
Wie ist das für euch, so auszugehen?
In 2 Std. müsst ihr wieder
nach Hause. Lohnt sich das?
Ich finde, es lohnt sich schon,
um mal etwas trinken zu gehen.
Aber sonst läuft ja auch gar nichts.
Gab es bei dir
eine aussergewöhnliche Betroffenheit?
Ich plante mit Freundinnen
Ferien im Sommer,
die nicht stattfinden konnten -
das war schade.
Wir wollten den Abschluss
des Jahres feiern.
Dass wir es geschafft haben.
Das ging aber nicht.
Auch unsere Bildungsreise und
das Sportlager wurden abgesagt.
Es kam immer mehr hinzu.
Dann dachte man sich schon:
"Nein, das auch noch."
Im Abschlussjahr ist die
Bildungsreise das Highlight.
Fühlst du dich manchmal auch beraubt?
Ja, manchmal
fühlt man sich schon eingeschränkt.
Man bekommt Anweisungen
von weiter oben und ...
Das ist sicher nicht einfach für uns.
Wenn man gerade 18 wird,
möchte man Neues kennenlernen.
Das ist nicht möglich.
Manchmal fragt man sich,
wann das aufhört.
Man wartet und hofft darauf,
doch es wird immer schlimmer,
dann wieder gut -
es ist ein Auf und Ab.